tueur est solide la sécurité et l'état
monsieur pascal thévenot
merci monsieur le président après notre
président de groupe
je tiens à exprimer toute ma compassion
au peuple belges eux monsieur le premier
ministre
comme chaque dirigeant de pme j'ai été
agréablement surpris par la version
initiale de la loi du travail vous
abonniez l'illusion de la protection des
salariés par la sanction des pme en
offrant un emploi nos chômeurs et un
espoir à notre jeunesse toujours oublier
des négociations vous sembliez redonner
envie d'embaucher à nos pme
le plafonnement des indemnités plus de
mal ne remet pas en cause le montant de
l'indemnité de licenciement qui reste un
droit
il limite simplement la sanction dans
l'entreprise par les prud'hommes
très souvent pour faute de procédure
procédure trop complexe pour une petite
entreprise
pourquoi y renoncer vous supprimez aussi
la possibilité de négocier
individuellement et imposer à une pme de
trouver un salarié mandaté par un
syndicat alors que vous faites le
constat que 90 % des pme se développe
sans représentation syndicale
monsieur le premier ministre vous
vouliez donner confiance aux pme pour
générer de la croissance
en cédant à vos frondeurs vous renforcer
les contraintes qui pèsent sur nos
petites entreprises et vous enfermez
notre jeunesse et nos chercheurs
d'emploi dans le chômage et la précarité
ce sont pourtant les pme les tpe qui
sont les vrais créateurs d'activité il
faut les soutenir et non les entraver
monsieur le premier ministre si vous
présenter demain
une fois seul travail vidé de sa
substance
les pme ne se feront plus d'illusions
sur ce texte
l espérons simplement limiter les dégâts
de contraintes supplémentaires
ne reculez pas
la parole est à madame myriam el khomri
ministre du travail dans l'emploi de la
formation professionnelle et du dialogue
social
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
thévenot permettez-moi en introduction
vous féliciter de votre élection
partielle le projet loi que je porte et
qui sera présenté en conseil des
ministres a fait l'objet de nombreuses
négociations négociations concertation
déjà suite au à la remise du rapport de
jean denis combrexelle
et puis en effet nous avons pris quinze
jours de plus et sur lequel nous avons
concerté l'ensemble des organisations
syndicales et patronales et donc le
projet que je présenterai jeudi reste
bien évidemment très audacieux puisqu'il
vise en effet à la fois à permettre de
développer la négociation collective
dans notre pays en laissant plus de
place à l'accord d'entreprise mais aussi
à les corps de branche et je sais que
les tpe et les pme sont très sensibles
au rôle de la branche
ce projet de loi permettra concrètement
à des tpe pme de bénéficier d'accords
type de branche ce qui est essentiel de
bénéficier également de la modulation du
temps de travail aujourd'hui permise
jusqu'à 28 jours et qui sera demain
permis jusqu'à neuf semaines
mais tous ces accords doivent en effet
être négociés et je crois que c'est
l'enjeu de ce projet de loi c'est de
trouver de nouvelles formes de
régulation sociale nous le portons j'en
suis particulièrement convaincu mais
c'est souplesse doit être négocié et
c'est pour ça que nous les élargissons
le mandatement pour le permettre
justement dans les tpe et pme
et puis il ya aussi dans ce projet loi
cette possibilité d'avoir une
plate-forme de l'ensemble des services
du ministère du travail des directs pour
aider notamment les tpe et pme qui sont
confrontés notamment à des questions
relatives au droit du travail
ce projet loi permet également de
nouveaux droits pour les salariés et les
demandeurs d'emploi notamment le droit à
l'information
combien d'années depuis combien de temps
nous parlons des difficultés que la
formation ne va pas ceux qui en ont le
plus besoin et c'est une question réelle
qui est posée aussi dans les tpe et pme
avoir un droit à la formation pour les
demandeurs d'emploi pour les salariés
qualifié pour l'aspect au service